NARRATOR: It's fair to
say that the relationship
between the United States
and Russia is tense at best.
Throughout their history,
the two countries
have been both
allies and enemies.
During the Cold War, the
US and the Soviet Union
were locked in an intense battle
that very nearly culminated
in nuclear war.
Thankfully, it didn't.
And in 1991, the Soviet Union
collapsed, ending the Cold War.
KSENIA YURKOVA: It's been
more than two decades
since the Soviet era ended.
Russia and its people
have moved on--
well, except for
towns like this.
Zarechny, its former
name was Penza-19.
It's one of the 44
last remaining closed
cities left in Russia.
Under Communism, it was
not even shown on the map,
and freedom of movement
was heavily restricted.
NARRATOR: That's Ksenia
Yurkova, a Russian photographer
who visited Zarechny, a closed
city southeast of Moscow.
Now you're probably wondering
what a closed city is.
Throughout the Cold
War, the Soviet Union
created 44 cities that were
kept secret from the world.
These cities were dedicated to
making weaponry, specifically
nuclear bombs.
The USSR was trying
to play catch-up
because in 1945, this happened.
REPORTER: The bomb was
exploded above the city,
and in the towering mushroom,
Japan could read its doom.
NARRATOR: The
American detonations
in Hiroshima and
Nagasaki kick-started
an arms race between
the US and Soviets
that would last for decades.
But the USSR didn't want
anyone knowing where
they were building their bombs.
So they created cities
that were, at the time,
impossible to find.
Secret cities likes
Zarechny existed
to make weapons without
interruption or interference.
But now, long after the Cold War
has ended, many of these cities
remain isolated, not just
from the rest of the world,
but from the rest
of the country, too.
KSENIA YURKOVA: The
city's 62,000 inhabitants
live encircled by a
fence of barbed wire.
They easily can leave the
city, but their guests
are allowed to visit only after
they obtain the invitation
from the locals, and only if it
is approved by the authorities.
The city is
beginning to open up,
but there are still parts of it
that are completely blocked off
from outsiders like Ksenia.
Today, Zarechny is still full
of out-of-bounds areas, most
notably Rose Autumn, the
state-owned corporation
to manufacture parts
for nuclear weapons.
Most of inhabitants
work on the main plant,
and help others connected
to that industry.
NARRATOR: Although work
here doesn't pay very well,
the work is steady,
food is cheap.
And although there's
not much else to do,
the local government does
provide some social programs
to keep the community happy.
Some commentators have
even described Zarechny
as a kind of
socialist wonderland,
a relic of the Soviet era.
Even so, in recent years,
some youth in the city
have expressed their desire
to leave, or at the very least
to have more freedom.
When Ksenia visited
the city, it was clear
that residents
were still subject
to the local government.
KSENIA YURKOVA:
People seem to be
not so free in their decisions.
It was rather visible
during the official parade
to due to anniversary
celebration,
when the most of workers
were forced to take part.
NARRATOR: In a lot of
ways living in Zarechny
really is like living in a
time capsule of Soviet life.
The people here
face restrictions
on their movements,
on their work,
and even on how they socialize.
But maybe residing
in this bubble,
away from the problems
of the wider world,
does mean that life is somewhat
easier, if a little dull.
KSENIA YURKOVA: The main
Russian political agenda
transmitted by mass media is
absolutely imperceptible here.
There is no attention to
the problems of immigrants,
external state policy,
minorities, gay prides,
and so forth.
The daily routine doesn't
assume any fluctuations.
Life is safe, measured,
and tranquil, even sleepy.
The inheritance of the
previous Soviet era.
NARRATOR: The Soviet era
was a tumultuous time
outside of Russia as well.
Our latest video takes
a look at the long road
to independence for
the Czech Republic.
Check that out now.
MAN: You can imagine how
transfixed I was by the news
when I started to hear
about demonstrations
against the Communist
regime in the fall of 1989.
NARRATOR: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.